Nepal is famous for its high Himalayas
but in the busy and Dusty Capital
Katmandu a high-end research lab is
flourishing Narayan at hiari is on his
way to truan
University after a decade working abroad
he came home to take the theoretical
physics department to a new
level so now we ar Central department of
trian
University this is the department where
I work and I'm one of the I one of the
professors out of 14 professors who are
working at this
department there is very little
government funding for basic science in
Nepal so Narayan has had to seek support
elsewhere one of the main funders is
ictp the International Center for
theoretical physics based in Italy and
supporting science in developing
countries so welcome to my office this
is the place where I work and I spend
most of my time I just have a laptop One
desktop and it is quite different than
what I had when I was working in
developed countries like
Italy Naran believes that training young
people is the best way to help his
Nation
develop he teaches a large MSC class and
supervises several PhD
students together they've produced a
stream of highlevel papers on the
properties of materials such as atom
thick graphine their achievements are
remarkable considering the many
challenges they faced including frequent
power Cuts so 16 hours per day there
will be no electricity in this building
from Nepal electricity
authority to solve that problem we have
solar power system and from that one
right now we get 2.3 KW power supply
uninterrupted or 24
hours making use of this power is an
ultra fast computer funded by ictp this
year it might not look like much but it
enables stuff to carry out some of the
complex calculations that are staple of
theoretical
research internet access however is
still a problem uh for example we have
internet from this University in this
building but uh it does not work most of
the time so most of the time if we need
to work at UH with internet we have to
be at
home
now today's day is over thank
you well not quite over over Narayan
also hosts evening discussions with his
students at his home which is just a
short bike ride from the University
campus okay now here we are in my study
room at home we generally discuss some
Physics in this room also with my P
students or Ms students in this room and
after some time we'll have dinner here
also Nana hopes that more young students
will study Physics in Nepal producing
quality work that can be published in
prestigious International journals and
eventually helping the country to
develop that's what he's working towards
day by
day